you're in Zoolander 2 is that right yeah  you shot it in Rome sudden I hear you  took in all the great sights of Rome is  that right I did I was in Rome and it  was such a beautiful city and I took  some pictures then yeah  with a self peace with a selfie stick  you brought this you actually brought  the selfie stick yes I brought a selfish  can we see some of that we are going to  see some of Fred's pictures in Rome with  this that just peaked rolling through  these there you go yeah there you are  [Applause]  it was where I think you're missing the  point of the South Pacific I was a good  investment yeah but you're enjoying it  wasn't that a great clip subscribe to my  youtube channel for an endless supply of  me  [Laughter]